as a mum of two my first baby was bottle
fed and my second was breastfed and both
Journeys had their moments
but when I made up my first bottle of
formula for my baby I remember my hand
shaking as I poured the powder his only
source of food into the bottle I'd never
done it before and I was making it up
under the pressure from the Hunger
scream
I can't imagine what that experience
would have been like if I'd have known
that I was just a few Scoops away from
an empty tub without any means to buy
another
it feels completely Unthinkable but with
the cost of baby formula going through
the roof rising up by 45 in the past two
years Sky News has spoken to desperate
parents across the country who are going
to drastic levels to make sure their
babies are fed and in some cases risking
their baby's health
I'm Leah belletto and this is the Sky
News Daily
[Music]
a bit later we'll be talking to a
pregnancy and baby expert who has told
us how the rocketing price of baby
formula could be fueling a potential
Public Health crisis but first our
correspondent Tom palminter has been
speaking to parents who are becoming
increasingly desperate a lot of babies
in different parts of the UK and this is
spread across the nation
are being put in very really challenging
and dangerous situations because the
parents through no fault of their own
just can't feed or afford to feed them
what they need because the cost of
formula is so much higher than it was
it's it's an essential product for some
families and the
discussions around breastfeeding versus
bottle feeding are well rehearsed and
it's almost a different issue to that
because this is
products that families rely on they
don't have any choice
over what they're giving their baby once
they've decided to to bottle feed and of
course some families do a mixture of the
two but it is something that is leading
parents to water down feeds so they
don't put as much powdered milk into the
bottles to try and stretch out the tub
and make it last longer they are in some
instances using condensed milk
as an alternative because it's cheaper
and a lot of families moving to cow's
milk far earlier than they should be the
recommended guidance is that it should
be around the 12 month Mark when you
start introducing cow's milk but a lot
of families because it's much cheaper
just move their baby onto cow's milk
much earlier we also found parents
stealing it and you can see on the
supermarket shelves all the security
measures in your local supermarket and
it's something that has increased over
the last year or two particularly and
yeah people putting themselves at Great
risk to steal it and also buying on the
black market this is something I didn't
really think was a thing but it is that
people
are buying knock down priced formula
from Juvia sources from people who are
stealing it in bulk and then selling it
on and then the online trade as well as
another layer of all this because people
are on
Marketplace
adverts looking through listings and
quite often those listings for formula
tubs are well meaning people not wanting
to put it in the building because it's
too precious to just throw away
and some of those tubs are sealed and
unopened and it wouldn't pose much of a
health risk but some of them are open
tubs that have been used they've had a
few Scoops out of them and for whatever
reason someone's decided they want to
give it away or or sell it
and people are buying those open tubs of
formula and we went to the Hartley pool
baby Bank up in the northeast of England
and they're just horrified by that
Prospect and they were just telling us
the health risks for those children yeah
you just don't know what is you don't
know what is in those tubs or how long
they've been opened and that is the risk
that some babies unfortunately are being
put into so Tom you said there people
are going to extraordinary lengths to to
get hold of baby formula and in some
instances they're they're going out and
they're stealing um talk to me about
some of those parents what they said to
you yeah we spoke to one mum and dad who
were down in the southwest of England
and we're not using their names and
we've obviously protecting their
identities for obvious reasons because
they were ready to
speak to us about the fact that when the
tub starts to run out and the formula is
looking thin for that week they
feel that they have to resort to
stealing from one of the local shops in
their town and that means the dad going
out
he's worked out
what he needs to do to do that he was
has been stopped a couple of times doing
it and challenged by store staff and
told to put the products back but he
continues to do it because he has to
feed his son and he said he's heard that
hungry scream
which
is a real piercing
sound
that has is still haunting him really
and
he's not prepared to
allow that to happen again to his son
and therefore he's doing
what a lot of people would feel is
beyond the pale but he's he's his
argument was that I'm going to look
after my son and that means I have to
steal it and the other thing he told us
when we were down in that town by the
sea was that he was meeting a woman
later that day who was selling a load of
knock down price baby formula and was
turning up in that town with a big bag
that he knew was stolen from elsewhere
and he would be buying it
for three pounds a tub
it's an entirely Black Market of selling
it stolen goods yeah and we spoke to
another dad up in
greater Manchester who was selling
online
tubs of formula eight of them out the
back of his car he's made a video where
he was showing the tubs of formula in
the back of his car and he admitted to
us that I I do get vouchers for my kids
but I'm not using baby formula but I'm
buying it with those vouchers and then
selling it on
on mine so you have this whole Black
Market wrapped up in this as well which
has popped up because of the cost of
baby formula you'll have been there and
I've been there as a dad and it's a
stressful difficult time when you're
tired and you're just trying to make the
right decisions and the reticence of a
lot of people to talk about this as an
issue is something that we've really
noticed and we've spoken to lots of
people
um in the background on all this who've
told us some of the other things that
they're having to do to try to afford
baby formula one mum that we spoke to
was
selling images of herself online quite
explicit images to make
the money to pay for baby formula and
and all these things it's a very
multi-layered story with lots going on
but ultimately at the heart of it a
British families who are really
struggling at the moment and
unfortunately British babies who are
being put in real Jeopardy so this is a
real problem isn't it it's happening up
and down the country what did you find
what is the reason that formula
is so much more expensive it's the cost
of making stuff that of course all
manufacturers of all kinds of foods have
been seeing but in the baby formula
industry the costs and we've asked all
the big companies and it's predominantly
the big multinational companies who make
these these Brands what's going on and
they say look we understand the
pressures that families are under but
our production costs are so much higher
than they were and they are trying to in
their words responsibly raise prices to
try to get that balance right between
paying their suppliers which include
farmers and also trying to make sure
that
families don't pay over the odds but
there is a lot of Fierce criticism as to
what is going on in this market and
we've got some new data from First Steps
nutrition that shows that the cheapest
brand of formula has risen by 45 over
the last two years and the average
across the whole Market is 24 up over
two years so
when you're trying to factor that into
all the other things that you have to
buy when you have a newborn baby it's a
big chunk of the weekly shop so listen
Tom what are the big worries here what's
at stake here if parents are watering
down formula if they're buying it online
if you know they're going out stealing
it we went to Newcastle as part of this
story and spoke to an infant feeding
specialist the consultant Dr Vicki
Thomas and she just pointed out to us
just how vital that first 12 months is
for for babies and for their parents
in terms of the development of babies
their weight will treble between the day
they are born and the day they turn one
and the Brain will double in size in
that first year and that is why the
nutrition that babies are getting in
that part of their lives is so vital yes
for when they're a baby but also it puts
the building blocks in place for the
rest of your life and your health in
future years into adulthood and she Dr
Vicki Thomas told us that this this is
an 80-year thing that we're setting up
here with the way that we feed babies
and therefore there is so much at stake
in terms of the health of
little ones and
she is in no doubt and others too
that we are on the brink of a Public
Health crisis in the United Kingdom
because of this
Tom we'll come back to you in a moment
but at this point I want to speak to
Claire Murphy from the British pregnancy
advice service that's a charity who
provides supports for women and mothers
and they say the price of formula has
become one of their biggest concerns I
I pricing Arrangements that have been
allowed to proliferate around formula
milk and I think that the issue is is
that it's really come to a head because
of the you know the the broader issues
there are around cost of living the kind
of choices that that families are having
to make and there will be some people
listening
um
who will say look if formula's too
expensive just breastfeed so I know
there's a bigger complication there but
for those people who say look you know
you decided to have a baby if it's too
expensive then just breastfeed well you
know we don't live in an ideal world do
we and there are all sorts of reasons
why and there's both physical and
practical challenges you know I mean we
talk about breastfeeding as being the
most natural thing in the world and you
know for some babies some you know women
and their babies it does it comes you
know really easily and it's you know
it's dinner you know the most convenient
you know best way possible to you know
to to feed your baby but that is a lot
of women don't have
um that experience their baby may have
tongue tie which which makes feeding and
latching latching to the breast very
difficult um you know they may have
problems with their milk supply and
absolutely we need to make sure that the
support services are in place for you
know for for those women who who want to
breastfeed to be able to do so and you
know and services have absolutely been
decimated uh in in recent years but we
also need to to recognize that actually
for some women it's it's not it's it's
not the right thing in in the context of
their lives in that moment and the needs
of their baby you know they may want to
share care with their partner
um for example or other members of you
know of of of the family
um they you know they they may be
looking after other young children and
you know and and and formula milk is a
much more convenient way to be able to
do that and give their other child the
care they need so I think sometimes we
divorce this issue it's it's it's it's
absolutely one of those things that by
all means you know let's make sure we
have the support services in place for
for women breastfeeding is really
important but also recognize that there
are a number of of issues and and
challenges that met that make it
inappropriate for other women what are
the consequences of watering down
formula and introducing cow's milk too
soon well it's nutritionally inadequate
that's the the you know the the short
answer is that
um you know babies move on to cow's milk
if that becomes their soul drink
um before they're ready if you know if
if milk is watered down it's not then
got the nutritional contents
um that it needs for that baby to to
thrive and to and to grow and develop
this situation puts us on the brink of a
Public Health crisis I think if you know
if people can't afford to feed their
babies adequately if they're not getting
adequate nutrition if if you know if
milk is being if milk is being watered
down it feeds are being spaced out you
know if
um
you know if people are so-called formula
foraging you know buying tins that may
be you know opened
um you know on online
all these things present risk
um and I think we're very you know we
focus a lot on breastfeeding and
breastfeeding for the health of of
infants and actually we think of
breastfeeding as a public health
initiative you know that that secures
the future health of of of babies well
we need to think of this in exactly the
same way that um you know most babies by
the time they are six months will be
being formula fed
um and we need to make sure there is a
safe sufficient affordable supply of
that product so that their health is not
being put at risk
um it's you know forming a milk is a is
a safe and acceptable alternative to to
to breastfeeding it needs to be
available and it needs to be affordable
what's the solution
do you think is there one I think this
needs a whole scale approach I think we
need to look at we need
we need start vouchers because
um I think we need to look as I say at
some of the messaging around this so
that there is understanding that you
know there is no nutritional difference
between the cheaper and the and the more
expensive product or you know the
choosing the cheaper product uh it's not
you know it's not it's not nutritionally
um inadequate
um and I think we absolutely need to
look at some of the the regulations
around
um you know the the the the the the sale
of this
um so for instance you know in in Europe
following the same World Health
Organization code on the marketing of um
breast milk substitutes you are
nevertheless allowed to use super you
are allowed to both use and collect
Supermarket vouchers uh on on formula
milk now I'm not saying for a moment
that's the answer but I think you know
the fact that we can't do that in this
country because it's seen as well this
could be promoting you know this could
be discouraging yes breastfeeding I mean
it's just it's it's patently observed
back to our correspondent Tom palmington
now it's it's incredible isn't it
because I think you mentioned it it's
that tiredness and I think particularly
when you're a first-time parent and you
would double you know you had twins so
it was it hit you even harder I bet but
it's that it's that tiredness it's that
doubting of your choices it's it's just
making sure that the baby's okay and
then on top of that list to think about
the fact that you wouldn't be able to
afford formula for your baby it's
heartbreaking and that's why when you
put it all together like that it does
amount to being on the brink of a Public
Health crisis according to multiple
people that we've spoken to in this and
they've also been quite grateful that we
have been able to highlight it in a way
to start that conversation with a lot of
people and to make sure that those who
do
have any influence on this be they
politicians be they
people in the industry that that it
needs to be looked at there needs to be
a discussion around it because you can't
go on like this in a modern country
allowing
this kind of Jeopardy
for the most vulnerable members of that
society and it is something that I think
will perhaps certainly get a lot of
focus because it is pretty shocking in
life say that as someone who's looked at
this quite in depth for a few months
that it is shocking what is happening to
British families and the decisions that
they are having to make and there will
be lots of people who are quick to rush
to condemn those families and and say
that they are making poor decisions but
just think about
how much any new parent wants to make it
work and wants to be do the best for
their baby and every mom and dad that
we've spoken to as part of this is in
that boat that they just want to do the
best but they're not being able to do
their best because of the high prices in
the shops
my thanks to Tom palminter Claire Murphy
and to you for listening to this episode
of The Sky News Daily this episode was
produced by Emma Ray Woodhouse and the
editor is Philly Beaumont